so I just did a comparison model we're  gonna use the same problem to use the  part part hole or the particle model  good draw again there are nine teachers  so I have nine teachers to be my  teachers represent that quantity nine  and six pants so I would add on to this  bar separate kwangji at six and they  would be the parents at the Singapore  Math info night how many people are at  the into a night so we are looking for  the total I would put my question mark  here and then I my bar model is complete  so I will go over here and I would do  nine plus six is equal to and instead of  doing separating the six I could  separate the nine into five and four so  that I make a 10 here so when I have 5  plus 10 which equals 15 there are 15  people at the inside  you